foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
someone go look up the definition of
obstruction
[Music]
an obstruction of justice
he told Molly Michael
you don't know nothing about those boxes
that you took pictures of that you were
taking notes of on the back a glass of
are you [__] [__] me
are you kidding me can you can you even
can you even imagine
I mean yesterday they couldn't stop
talking about John fetterman's [__]
hoodie they couldn't stop talking about
it I mean it was incredible they kept
going on and on and on and on about John
vetterman's hoodie
I'm gonna show some of those clips today
they got hoodie brain
[Music]
[__] chuckleheads
can you imagine
if Joe Biden or Barack Obama was having
some [__]
take notes on the back of classified
documents can you even can you even [__]
just think about it for a second
it would be non-stop 24 7 about how they
should be impeached and sent to gitmo
and charged with treason all kinds of
crazy ass tan suit type [__]
I'm serious
this would be all out [__] a media
frenzy and it wouldn't just be the
[__] right wing
I mean [__] the mainstream media can't
stop focusing on how old Biden is
they're like yeah he's got an age he he
has a birthday too it's kind of crazy
and and he he's still a president we
really we we need a story we need a
great story in the our stories suck
because we suck at stories they're
really horrible at it
they want this race to be so close don't
they the media wants this race to be 50
50. so [__] bad so much so that
they're rigging up a bunch of pulls to
puke down our [__] our our [__]
society to act like this is a 50 50 Race
it's not get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense if you're believing polls
then you're the one being duped okay
you're it's it's all [__]
all of it
it's all [__] [__] just go out
and ask anyone that you know even in
manga country if they really like Donald
Trump then you gotta ask them in private
you can't do it in public because they
ain't gonna admit to it in public if
they're around their stupid dumb ass
Republican friends
people don't like that [__] they
don't
and they definitely don't like some dude
not taking our country's secret
seriously
so much so that he's having someone
taking [__] notes on the back of him
as if they're what the [__] did so the
guy eats classified documents
he eats them they must taste wonderful
we know that he's [__] chewing up
notes and [__] in meetings
he he [__] uses them as scrap paper
he uses them it's toilet paper it seems
he had him in his [__] bathroom
what do you want from me I don't get to
make this [__] up
we're just in the weirdest [__]
timeline ever we're the former president
United States was so so unconcerned
about our secrets in our country and our
national security that he was [__]
eating notes
using using classified documents as
scrap paper toilet paper who knows maybe
he was using them as net napkins to
clean up the ketchup Off the Wall [__] I
don't know
and then he's used him as bragging
rights in front of people who can't see
him come on man this isn't [__]
rocket science a rocket surgery as it is
with Maga
he's a [__] treasonous piece of [__]
but that's what they love about him
it's incredible it's incredible
it's wild stuff
his assistant not only Not only was she
in the white house she was hired to go
to with him to mar-a-longo she's the one
who took the [__] pictures of the
boxes
and this [__] goes to Jack Smith
and special counsel of course she can't
lie you know I mean she can't because
they have the [__] evidence
that's what I keep saying about these
interviews that he gives yeah is he
[__] kind of admitting of guilt in
some of these interviews yeah but that
ain't gonna make a difference
I mean it's great for us to politicize
it and it's great for the country to see
that he's such a [__] chucklehead
but really honestly in the court alone
Jack Smith's got way better evidence
than this [__] idiot sitting in an
interview a shitty ass capitulation
interview with [__] Kristen Welker
the new host of Meet the Press which she
should be the last host to Meet the
Press to be quite honest with you they
should just take that [__] off the air
100 just take it I know it's a great
institution in our country as far as the
Press is concerned but they've destroyed
its reputation
and they destroyed the institution of
Meet the Press Chuck Todd Kristen Welker
the first interview the first [__]
piece of content that they put out get
the [__] out of here just cancel that
[__] take it off TV it ain't even it
ain't even worth keeping the [__]
brand if you want to know the honest
truth the media is so [__] it's so
[__] horrible at this
they suck at this so [__] bad
so bad I mean there's a few of them that
are really good right we we know that
there's a few that are really good
but they're not they're not given the
spots that they need to be given
no way would Trump be interviewed by
Mindy yassan no [__] way no [__]
way not in a million years
not in a million years will he go up
against many assigned no [__] way and
that's why many assigns should be the
the [__] moderator of Meet the Press
if they're gonna make it stand
they should be terrified to go on Meet
the Press terrified
terrified these [__] fascists
standing on their Foundation of their
[__] lies
so much so that they don't go on Meet
the Press that's the point
that's the point
I mean I'm not opposed to someone
interviewing these [__] fascists you
just gotta do it in the correct way
it's enough of this [__]
oh [__] and we find out that he's he was
having people take he wasn't he wasn't
like
oh my God we gotta write this idea down
oh man this is a great idea we can't
lose this here grab this classified
document right in on the back of that no
he was having he was leaving notes for
them to do [__] like it was scrap paper
like it was Post-it notes
and we're supposed to take the idea that
this guy considers National Security a
high priority yeah [__] out of here
that's what we're supposed to think
and then and then the fact that she is
testifying that he told her you don't
know [__] about those boxes [__]
don't say no goddamn word when you go
talk to Jack Smith about them boxes
unbeknownst to him he's an idiot that's
obstruction of justice it's a [__]
felony
and she goes and she's like well you
just committed another felony so now I
gotta tell the [__] special
counselman prosecutor that [__]
the dumbest [__] person on Earth
what a stupid son of a [__]
how in the [__] did we get in this
timeline when you think about it really
honestly you're like Jesus [__]
Christ so we weren't gonna trust the
email lady because she had one email
that may have had a classified marking
that may have been wrong
that's we traded away
that for [__] this guy who's eating
who's eating notes who's making who's
using classified documents as Post-its
and scrap paper flushing [__] down the
toilet
he's hiding boxes and and obstructing
justice and making sure that people
don't tell the Department of Justice
and Nara that he has these what in the
[__] are what the [__] are you people
thinking
hurry males oh my God there's a server
with emails on it about her daughter's
wedding and how she [__]
needs to take Metamucil probably Jesus
[__] Christ
and they're gonna do it again
they're gonna do it again
this will be the third time they've tied
their ankle around the city before they
throw the cinder blocks into the ocean
but they're gonna do it they're gonna do
it again
they might do it more than one more time
who the [__] knows God we can only hope
that
a Big Mac saves us here or several Big
Macs not gonna lie buckets of chicken I
mean just start just shoveling it down
Grandpa's throat honestly [__] just I
don't know if if fast food wants to do
us a really big service in this country
what they should do is all band together
and you know what we're gonna give a
lifetime free free load of food to
Donald Trump as much as you can eat
Fatso as much as you can eat
just a [__] Buffet of cardiovascular
failure
I don't know what do you want from me
that it feels like the Republicans are
not going to walk away from him
it kind of feels like that
all the media wanted it so bad
oh they wanted it so bad in January and
February when I was telling you that
there's no way there's no way Rhonda's
anthis is going to be the nominee
there's no way anyone is going to come
up at the top of the Heap then Trump
trump is going to be the nominee
no matter what no matter he could he
could croak today and they would still
nominate him
they [__] think JFK Jr still alive
folks
[__] you want from me I don't again I
don't get to make this [__] up
I'm just here to tell you the real raw
truth
[__] give you the Cold Truth whether you
like it or not I don't know
what to do about it other than to just
tell you this [__]
in a way that you need to hear it not
some [__] where you're like oh well
uh is is Joe Biden too old to be
president and is President Trump gonna
have a good policy on energy what the
[__] [__] out of here with those type
headlines
no one's buying that [__] I mean and if
you are you're a deluded sheep
if you're out there talking about how
old Joe Biden is
honestly if thought even enters your
[__] mind
if it even enters your mind you need to
seek some [__] help you need to get
some [__] help here I don't give a
[__] if you're on my side or not you
know and I I've been a lot of people uh
have not been happy with me for speaking
out against our side oh Tony they're our
Ally well the problem is is that they're
not really steeped in the foundation of
democracy
they're saying they're they're saying
things that sound
liberal
but in all honesty they're both sides
and [__]
and there is no both sides to democracy
either [__] believe in it or you
don't and if you don't believe in
democracy fine sit this one out sit down
and shut the [__] up
it's what we need to have happen just
[__] down and shut the [__] up if you
don't believe in democracy
we've got a nation to save here
and we're dragging around a dead body of
the Republican Nazi party
and they can't even oh my God they they
seriously they are [__] dead dead
dead dead dead you want to know how dead
they are they had a civil war inside
their party
and manga one
that's how dead they are it's a carcass
stinks you ever you ever you ever had a
carcass like on the edge of the highway
and it's like a thousand degrees outside
and it's been sitting there for a couple
days that motherfucker's so bloated it's
gonna pop and that son of a [__] just
stinks to high heaven oh my God so
[__] disgusting maggots rats [__]
Crow vultures are vultures and rats
won't even touch this [__]
that's the Republican Party
that dead carcass on the side of the
road
that we as America refuse to clean up
because it's so goddamn disgusting
even the former members of their party
are like well I I really don't like them
that much
I mean I'm still I'm still Republican
I'm still because I'm conservative
[__] out of here
go clean your [__] mess up on the
side of the road okay go clean your
roadkill up
it's enough of this [__] but nope
nope can't do that you have Matt gatz
and Byron Donald's performing theater
at at the [__] Peril of our country
and our economy yes they are gonna shut
the government down they're gonna do it
I set it back in [__] February in
March that they are going to shut down
the government in September they don't
have a choice well Kevin McCarthy has
two choices he has two only two choices
he can bandwidth the Democrats to get a
CR to keep our government open and keep
governing and lose his speakership or he
can capitulate to Donald Trump and manga
which do you think that [__] coward
is gonna choose oh man it's really hard
to figure out what Kevin McCarthy's
gonna do what the coward is going to do
is he going to capitulate the Trump and
manga it's almost like there's a history
of this
[__] out of here this is not hard to
understand media it's not hard to
understand you stupid bastards this is
the dumbest [__] I've ever seen it's
[__] stupid as
dumb that the media is standing around
going well I could have shut the
government down where are they gonna
[__] yes yes yes
they're gonna shut the government down
they do not have the votes to keep it
open you stupid bucks these people are
lunatics
I mean Jesus Christ you got people
juicing the beetle out there in Denver
you got Matt Gantz who is an accused sex
offender standing on the floor
chastising chastising Byron Donalds
who's a felon
who who was the one if you remember
Byron Donald's really made Headway into
the media they promised him he was going
to be a superstar when he did what they
wanted during the Kevin McCarthy vote do
you remember this no one knew who the
[__] he was not one [__] knew
who Byron Donald was now he's all over
Fox News because they made a deal we're
gonna make you a star baby because
that's what this is all about it's all
about them the stardom of it for them
they don't give a [__] about the people
who voted for him they don't give a [__]
about the country they don't give a [__]
about our national security and they
definitely don't give a [__] about our
constitution not one not one [__] they
only care about their [__] influence
and their [__] power and they know
that their influence and them [__]
suckling at the teat of trump allows
them to somehow become a superstar on
social media and Fox News Trader TV well
[__] me running that's where we're at
and you think I'm I'm out of turn to say
that the Republican party is dead the
[__] out of here man
this guy was having leaving notes on the
back of classified documents a to-do
list
treating it as if they were Post-it
notes
and you think you think him and his
allies and the people who who support
him give a [__] about our national
security let alone our [__] country
and our constitution you're out of your
goddamn mind
pluck your head out of your ass for two
seconds
two seconds and realize Joe Biden had a
box of documents next to his Corvette oh
my God Mike Pence had a few files in his
house oh my God they were mispact this
guy was having people take notes and
making notes on the back of classified
documents as if they were scrap paper
you stupid [__] he was flushing [__]
down the toilet he was eating classified
notes
and he continued to obstruct even with
the person who he was making notes on
the back of classified documents telling
her oh those boxes you took pictures of
you know nothing about those boxes
he's a [__] Criminal
they don't care
they don't care you can you can lay
these facts out for him over and over
and over and over again and you know
what they're gonna say well what about
what about the email lady what about
those the non-evidence of Hunter Biden's
cockpits that he was selling to China
and that money went directly to Joe
Biden's pocket what about that huh huh I
mean they're just gonna make up whatever
the [__] they gotta make up
and there ain't goddamn thing to do
about it there ain't a goddamn thing the
media can do about it you're not gonna
do anything about them being [__]
delusional brain dead and stupid you
can't fix it you can't fix stupid it
doesn't work that way the only thing you
can do is point it out and go look
that's really [__] dumb don't the
rest of you agree that's really [__]
dumb okay let's not do that dumb thing
that those people over there are doing
you can do that
media you pieces of trash
Gavin Newsom Gavin Newsom does an
interview with CNN I'll show you the
clip today
and he's asked about Joe Biden's age
and rather Kamala Harris should be on
the ticket
are you fi these are the hard-hitting
questions that you want to ask
the person that obviously the media
believes that Gavin Newsom should be
running other than Joe Biden which is
not how it works if Gavin Newsom thought
he could win which he couldn't Gavin
Newsom would get his ass stomped by Joe
Biden in a primary Newsome knows it he's
basically saying it hey he's the best
and most effective president that we've
ever had and if I'm president I'm gonna
strive to be like him
[__] wrong with you people
it's almost it's almost like the media
it's more brain dead than manga to be
quite honest it [__] seems that way
doesn't it
when they do these stupid things they
try to they try to use media like they
did with Trump with Biden it's really
stupid [__]
because the media still hasn't they're
still in the Trump Loop right they're in
this Trump Loop where they they're
constantly thinking oh well this
President is doing something and he's
going there and that's that's this thing
and oh boy we're they're reverse
engineering crimes [__] out of here
the dude is getting up putting his shoes
on and going and doing his job he
doesn't give a [__] when his date of
birth is
okay he doesn't give a [__] I saw a
picture the other day of the president
and the first and I don't talk about the
president that much but they're forcing
me to which really pisses me off that
pisses me off more than anything that I
gotta sit here and defend [__] Joe
Biden
that [__] pisses me off that is not
the [__] commentary that I think is
best okay it's not you shouldn't have to
sit and defend someone that is easily
defendable all she gotta do is I don't
know [__] work you know scrounge up
some facts and [__]
pisses me off that I have to sit here
and defend defend someone who is
effective it's [__] infuriating
it should be infuriating to you too
and anyone who says his age you should
[__] just jump all up and down their
ass
just like Newsome does in this interview
but it's [__] ridiculous Joe Biden in
the first lady here I am talking about
Jesus [__] Christ standing on the
beach the dude is standing on one foot
with this other foot behind him
stretching his leg
have can you
he rides a [__] bike
okay
I'm in my 30s
I can stand and stretch my leg and I can
get on a bike and ride but I probably
can't do it as well as Joe Biden okay
it's to be quite honest I'm still kind
of chubby I like pizza and hot dogs way
too [__] much probably I like to
drink you know I like to get high and
eat candy yeah yeah you know you get the
[__] munchies
Jesus [__] Christ
the dude stole our classified forget
forget the [__] treason part of him
trying to overthrow the government for a
minute if we just set that crime aside
where he was trying to overthrow our
democracy commit a Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup let's set that aside let's go for
the felonies after he committed that
felony
the [__] stole documents took
them down to marlongo had them in places
that you shouldn't have them
rather he knew it or not it doesn't
matter but he did know it he did know it
and the reason why I didn't know it's
because when they came to get him he's
like nope I got him no no no no no we
don't have any of that and then when the
lawyer is like no you have some of that
he's like well just tell him we don't
that'd be cool right they won't come
back if we tell them we don't have them
and they're like no they're gonna come
back oh yeah they got a warrant to
search they're gonna [__] gather up a
bunch of [__]
Molly Michael apparently had some of
these classified documents with notes in
it in her [__] death drawer
because it was a [__] it was a scrap
piece of paper at that point
and when she found them after the FBI
had been there she had to contact the
[__] doj and say hey I got more [__]
and like whoa what is it they're like
well she's like well it's classified
documents but you'll never believe this
see he likes to write notes on them like
there are scrap pieces of paper
and leave notes for me
what
what the [__] did you just say
he's also freaking out that Jeffrey
Clark and Mark Meadows is turning on him
not to mention
oh my God I can't even I can't even
believe I [__] have to say this out
loud
not to mention the guy post the other
day
that American Jews liberal Jews are
gonna regret their decision
Hitler much I mean I don't know why
people get so [__] the right gets so
pissed off when I
give you and show you a connection from
point A to point B trumpism to Nazism uh
manga to Nazis I don't know how why you
get so [__] pissed off at me
I mean they're on an overpass supporting
Ron DeSantis and then he's on his true
social his fraud Social account
posting that liberal Jews American
liberal Jews are going to regret their
decisions
whoo baby
you you try to figure it out
you try to figure it out for a second
but it's nothing to figure out
that's what the media is trying to do
they're trying to figure out oh we're
trying to figure it out oh wow well
maybe we'll maybe we'll do this no that
ain't gonna work for him maybe we'll do
this maybe we'll bash Biden for a bit
that'll be a good that'll be good we'll
get headlines that we'll get profit that
way well we'll call him old you know
because he's he's old
even though Donald Trump's just as
[__] old as he is and Joe Biden can
ride a [__] bike Donald Trump can
barely drive a golf court that fat [__]
that that'll make a good headline
that'll really distract him oh and then
we'll get a stupid ass pull that says
that they're neck and neck even though
they're not [__] neck and neck we'll
just rig it up a bit we'll rig it up so
it looks like they're neck and neck that
way you stay tuned because you're
terrified you're terrified that Joe
Biden the most effective president of
our [__] modern history somehow
his neck and neck with the most
unpopular [__] ever in our
country Donald Trump get the [__] out of
here with this [__]
and if you're going over to MSNBC or CNN
or wherever the [__] you're going and
you're and you're letting them shovel
that [__] in your mouth well then you
you deserve you deserve to have [__]
[__] for breath if you're gonna let them
shovel that dog [__] in your mouth
and believe it
[__] out of here
and I'm gonna keep attacking the media
it's gonna happen I'm gonna keep going
after him now I think I'm making Headway
because some of the commentators it
appears that they're listening to
something
maybe not me listen to me
maybe just maybe if we as a as a
coalition of pro-democracy [__] em fam
get out there and just [__] pound the
Airways with these [__] messaging
that they suck and it sucks to suck
maybe they'll get their act together by
the time we get to the primaries because
we're really gonna need their act
together when we get to the primaries
but they're not going to they're going
to normalize Trump and his criminal ways
when he starts winning the Iowa caucus
and he wins in New Hampshire he goes
down he wins on super Tuesday oh my God
you [__] slam dunk super Tuesday and
it's over
they're gonna normalize the [__] out of
him just like Christian Welker did the
other day on Meet the Press
oh Mr President
can I can I get you anything like the
normalization of your criminality
[__] out of here with that [__] that's
why you come here every single weekday
Monday through Friday near Eastern 11
Central nine Pacific right here on
YouTube Facebook and twitch
we've got lots of expansion going on
here at the Tony Michaels podcast stay
tuned don't go anywhere I'm going to
tell you more about it when we get back
right after this message
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them Buckle [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Texas fall is not going to be joining us
uh for a couple weeks he's out on
vacation
just got me here on Taco Tuesday I know
I gave Sanchez is probably going to join
us at the at the end of the show because
we're gonna throw into Gabe's Joe
I don't know if you noticed but Gabe
Sanchez has not been co-hosting as much
here because he has his own hour now
right after our show regularly on
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays this
week Monday and Tuesday because of his
vacation
but we will be throwing to Gabe Sanchez
after the show on Tuesdays Wednesdays
and Thursdays so stick around don't go
anywhere right after this show you'll if
you're on the main YouTube channel or
the twitch Channel
you'll be forwarded directly to Gabe's
engines as long as the twitch is working
yesterday it didn't work as well but it
finally worked everyone got over there
everyone was watching on Twitch and on
YouTube
speaking to Twitch and YouTube do not
forget to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast it's
free99 to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast it doesn't cost you a single
night YouTube wouldn't give me money
anyways
they wouldn't they wouldn't give me
money
they don't like me that much at all
really honestly they hate my guts
but if you do want to support the show I
do appreciate it and I appreciate all
the support that you guys have given
there was a couple venmode super chats
yesterday so if you want to get on that
you just go to thetonymichaels.com you
go to thetonymichaels.com you can see it
right
right here there's the venmo Super Chat
there it'll take you directly to the
venmo you can send me a message make
sure you have your handle and whatever
platform you're watching on so I can
give you a shout out for those venmo
super chats catch that there also if you
want to buy a shot if you want me to do
a shot of Jaeger
and go buy insurance I appreciate
everyone who's been supporting us uh
either through patreon the venmo super
chants or The Taking of a shot it means
a lot to me but more than anything
engaging is the most important support
that we get here at the Tony Michaels
podcast so go ahead and hit subscribe at
the top of the Tony michaels.com and
you'll be subscribed to all the changes
every day I'll send you an email with
the new with the new episode if we
change anything we have something new
that's going on
then we'll let you know like I'm gonna
let you know right now
there's something really cool happening
out there
and we talked about it over the weekend
and
and I mentioned it yesterday a little
bit about the library of democracy
um you know we had the round table of
democracy we're doing discussions we
thought it needed an upgrade as well and
we did we gave it an upgrade we're
calling it the library of democracy and
we're we have its own YouTube channel
and I appreciate everyone going over and
helping us get as many subscribers on
that channel as possible but I want to
show you something here really quick
um here is the library of democracy's
YouTube channel right here and I want to
show you there's 98 subscribers right
now no only 98 so get over there right
now the library of democracy let me give
you the um the YouTube channel link here
in the chat that way you can go
subscribe right now while you're on the
show while you're on YouTube
go ahead and if you're not on YouTube
get over to YouTube and subscribe to
this channel oh that's not what I want
I messed that up hang on a second we'll
get it I promise I promise here hang on
I pushed the wrong button
all right here it is here is the library
of democracies
um the the link and you can just type in
the library of democracy on YouTube and
you can subscribe let's see if we're
over a hundred we got to get the library
of democracy oh 117 look at that boom
there's like 20 of you keep going don't
stop don't stop let's get this thing
let's get this thing to a thousand as
fast as we can there's 133 God damn it's
like a slot machine let's just keep
refreshing oh maybe 143 143 you give me
150 180 150 147 147 100 feet
I know there's 150 you guys are awesome
you know you're the best audience in the
world uh and I appreciate you guys to
support so much and it's gonna be mean
so much at the library democracy uh to
be to be subscribed over there because
we're gonna show we're gonna show you
how that you can engage in simple easy
ways um the mighty librarian is going to
be putting together a lot of content
we'll be doing some lives we'll be doing
some interviews some other content over
there that and alls it is is about
engaging in your democracy things that
you can do little helpful tips little
helpful things go subscribe at the
library of democracy you're not going to
want to miss out
on some of those tips and tricks and
it's really fast easy stuff that you can
do or find that you can do the other
nice part is that here's the thing is
that if you if you have someone who
doesn't know what to do
you can say hey here's this channel I
watch the videos and they're really good
go check it out
go check it out this is what you can do
for your democracy there's going to be
so many things not just things like
field team six Now find calls.org
ballotpedia there's so many resources
out there that are at our fingertips we
just have to glue them together okay
that's what we got to do there's so many
resources out there for the
pro-democracy Coalition already we don't
have to like reinvent the wheel we just
have to glue them all together and
that's the idea of the library of
democracy is providing you not just with
those resources but but the content to
make it easy to know how to use that
those resources so make sure you're
subscribing at the library of democracy
I appreciate it so much let's see let's
see what the uh the ticker says here
dude 240. holy [__]
okay let's see if we can get it to a
thousand honestly let's see if we can
get this thing to a thousand I know
there's there's a thousand there's
there's almost 1800 people watching
right now so I know we can get this
thing to a thousand before the end of
the show we'll keep checking back in
with the library democracy it's at 240
right now at 244. so I mean it just
keeps going up every single second so
get over to the library of democracy let
me put the um let me put the link in the
chat one more time uh let's see let's
get it in there one more time that we
can go over and you just again you just
search library of democracy the library
of democracy use the link in the chat to
get over there and subscribe uh the way
you can
and and I'm telling you you're not going
to regret this uh as this content rolls
out and as we get better and better at
it because in the lead up to the next
election it's going to be important that
we engage in our democracy and find ways
to engage in our democracy it's super
important
and and this content is going to lead
you not just the content but the
resources that are going to be at your
fingertips not only for because it's
Constitution Day did you know that and
it's like National registration uh
registration day for voting
right those are two big things that are
going on today A lot of people are
talking about the Constitution and talk
about registering to vote
boom
that is going to be so important when we
go in to this 2024 election which is the
most important election of our
democracy's lifetime I mean let's face
it we got the choice between one of the
most effective presidents that we've had
in modern history or a guy who uses
classified documents as scratch paper
and toilet paper right he wipes his ass
and takes notes on classified documents
which one are you gonna choose
one of them one of them is standing in
front of the Union defending democracy
defending the sovereign state of Ukraine
the other one capitulates to Putin
what do you want which one you want huh
you want one that defends democracy all
around the world huh or you want one
that's gonna that wants to get in bed
with the the person who's trying to kill
democracies all around the world [__]
out of here man
this isn't complicated stuff it really
isn't when you're like apples oranges or
if you're like an actual president and
an orange when you're comparing those
two like hey here's an actual present
and here's an orange compare them
so get over to the library of democracy
and figure out a way that you can share
this with your family your friends the
people in your community your church
members uh the people on the PTA with
you if they want to know how to engage
in their democracy this content is going
to show them the way holy moly it's up
to 320 subscribers now
you know this is going to make the
mighty Librarians super happy she's
actually I don't think she's actually
watching right now
um and here's the reason why because
it's Constitution Day so like Librarians
are super super busy uh on Constitution
Day because you know they it's one thing
the Librarians do is they generally
speaking they believe in the
Constitution uh so make sure we give the
mighty librarian a great great surprise
when she finally peeks her head out this
afternoon and looks at this Channel and
sees this channel has absolutely gone
Bonkers and that you guys have taken it
to over a thousand subscribers in a
matter of minutes
um it it means it'll mean a lot to her
it means a lot to me and you guys are
the best audience in the world you truly
are and the reason why is because you
are so loyal to the engagement of
democracy you know I was talking about
dissent yesterday
like that that's key to democracy is
dissent like that's the thing that makes
democracy go round is dissent well
education too but you know
that's a whole nother freaking topic
that would take me four hours to talk
about but I like that that you you
challenge me sometimes sometimes but no
you do sometimes you challenge me you
know people um they when I talk against
the media or are against tyt or David
packman or you know they don't like when
I do that kind of stuff or when I'm
talking about against Glenn about the
14th that dumb [__] that he's talking
about a lot of people a lot of people
challenge me and I like that it's good
it's good that you challenge me because
what it does is it makes me defend my
position
and there's there's something there's
something that needs to be said about
anyone in this country who can defend
their position
I mean you see Lauren bobert
you talk about [__] what a coward
right
there's no strength in that at all
she go you know I don't give a [__] that
she was you know juicing this Beetle
really in the in the theater that
doesn't bother me at all whatever do
what you want to do
you know they they didn't have they he
didn't have us pecker out she didn't
have her titties out you know whatever
right they were they were horny they
were on their first date apparently uh
but when you lie when you lie and you
have your staff lie about vaping and
then you're like oh it was our first
date he's a Democrat that's why because
because Hunter Biden's laptop or some
[__] that's why I was you know
getting down with him juicing his beetle
in the theater you know like whatever
but the whole hypocrisy of it all the
latter pulling that really pisses me off
but
but she's weak she's weak because she
won't defend her position right
she won't defend her position
on anything really because it's
indefensible if you want to know the
honest truth then there's so many other
reasons why Lauren Boomer shouldn't be a
congresswoman playing playing playing
[__] pocket pool in Beetlejuice uh
theatrical Musical
in a dark crowded room is not really at
the very top of the list for her of why
she should not [__] be a sitting
member of Congress
it's that she can't defend her positions
because they're indefensible and if you
can't defend your positions well get
[__] honestly that's how it should be
if you can't defend your positions
especially when you defend your
positions with just outright lies
right
so again again I I appreciate the
dissent here from you
that means you're thinking that means
you're using the brain cells that you
got left to rub together some in our
country do not do that
they refused to do that
so I appreciate the audience here
um using what power they have to promote
democracy and again to even dissent
it's good that's the questioning
Authority
and Truth to power is the reason why our
democracy will live
it will live
um someone asked here hey Tony can you
please post a resource of the places we
can send postcards to to voters in a
library in the library yes there will be
so um there's also a playlist
um and we did one on uh field team six
and they do postcards we did a couple
videos on field team six they're on this
channel right now that's why I want to
have its own channel its own place where
it exists so it's easy to find those
resources
and it's and it doesn't have the Tony
Michaels podcast plastered all over it
it's just the library of democracy it's
its own separate thing
um but you can go to the playlist here
on the Tony Michaels podcast you'll see
the round table of democracy see we're
rebranding it you can see the Roundtable
democracy and there's a couple videos in
there that are marked field team six and
they talk about
um field team six does postcards and
we're gonna do more and more and more of
those we want to do that um I want to
have the um founder of fivecalls.org we
want to do a video with them in the
library of democracy I'll probably have
them on the show too so you guys can see
them on the show and then you can have
more of a like a workshop type video on
the library of democracy because it's
not it's not also important to have them
like come on the show and Bash
Republicans and manga that's great I
like doing that that's fun
um but we want more substantive
educational uh material that gives you
the exact way that you can engage in
your democracy and use the resources
that are already out there right so like
we don't have to invent new resources
that's why it's a library we just
collect the resources and put it in the
library for you to check out for you to
use for you to read for you to consume
whatever piece of the library that you
want to do because I'm sure it's going
to go well beyond the YouTube channel
it's probably going to be a website and
there's going to be a digital resource
gallery and stuff like that but it takes
time to do all that
um so we're gonna do it one piece at a
time but one piece of the time is for
you guys to go subscribe to that YouTube
channel and boy have you
365 total
so at 365 now if you're listening right
now please do me a huge favor and go
subscribe to the library of democracy's
YouTube channel maybe if I can post it
again I'm gonna post it in the chat
again here go follow this uh And
subscribe to the library of democracy
and get us get us to a thousand today
that'd be a great a great gift
to the mighty librarian on Constitution
Day to give her a thousand subscribers
over on the library of democracy so do
that for us today you're the best
audience in the world okay let's um
let's do this let's take another well
we're not quite to the top
so let's let's talk about something real
quick and then I'll take a break I'm the
only one here today here that yeah you
just got me that's it there's no there's
no other [__] just me today
whether you like it or not
um
so
um yesterday let's play this because
this is kind of a joke yesterday
Republicans didn't have anything else to
[__] about I mean because they're being
questioned like time and time again
you're gonna shut down the government
you're going to shut this is really
stupid you're gonna just shut down the
government you're gonna shut down the
government and like oh wait wait wait
she says Joe Biden Joe Biden in the
hunter Biden's dick pics that's really a
coven see where they're going to have
lockdowns with masks and it's going to
shut down the and lock down the the
government and we'll I mean we really do
we don't want to uh we don't want to
um
this is what they sound like
I'm dead serious that's what they sound
like but yesterday amidst all that
all that [__] I'm about to shut down
because they're gonna do it they're
gonna shut it down I don't know what
they'll tell you
amid all that [__] they were super
[__] focused on John fetterman's
hoodie
I'm not kidding you uh someone asking uh
Brendan here is asking what happened to
Texas Paul he's just on vacation for a
couple weeks he had he had several two
he's got a couple Tuesdays here he's got
some some uh things that he's got
planned so he couldn't make it on
Tuesday no big deal no big deal he'll be
back in a few weeks he'll be back in a
few weeks
um so
big staff fan says Tony is never in a
loss for words I can find words all the
time oh the best words I have the best
words
I know the best words ever even if
they're wrong even if people correct me
in the chat then I'm saying it wrong
that I'm pronouncing the word wrong I
still have the best they're the best
words they're the best words ever
accordion accordion accordion accordion
jack off some giraffes the best words
ever I'm sorry
I apologize for that
I don't know what to tell you I don't
want Texas ball here so I got to fill
the space
okay well speaking of jokes
um let's go to Ron DeSanto oh [__]
that's not what I want hang on a second
hang on a second I gotta switch I gotta
switch my screens here
um we're gonna go to Ron DeSantis here
and he's gonna be he's gonna be sharing
with us why it's so important that we
know about fetterman's
sweater his hoodie now again not only is
this Rhonda Santa saying this [__] he's
saying it in a [__] Firehouse like in
front of a [__] fire truck okay
all right keep that in mind here now the
other thing too is this conservative
Outlet Florida's voice
thinks this is a good thing they're like
yeah yeah Rhonda said this is he's
talking about fetterman in a hoodie
okay
all right this is the big news on the
right wing today that fetterman wears a
hoodie as if they didn't know that
already but here you go let's listen
let's listen to meatball tell us why
it's better to eat pudding with your
fingers
but you gotta do it in a suit you can't
do it in a hoodie
so I don't did you guys hear the U.S
Senate just eliminated its dress code
because you got this guy from
Pennsylvania
who's got a lot of problems I mean let's
just be honest like how he got elected
well I mean he got elected because they
didn't want the alternative but um yeah
because the alternative is [__] because
I don't know they were capitulating to
people like you Dr Oz I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you something
about Dr Oz and and Federman here in a
minute that was made during that
campaign and it's it's gold so we're
gonna watch that and it has to do with
Ben Shapiro which Ben Shapiro is trying
to protect Russell Brand and then the
the rape out allegations which is not
surprising
um but here Ron DeSantis let me tell you
something meatball let me give you a
clue here buddy I've told you time and
time and time again
to drop and just just stop being the
governor of Florida you'd have a lot
better chance of being Trump if you
would have done this back when he got in
New York you would actually be the front
runner here if you'd have listened to me
she didn't [__] listen to me I tried
to get you to listen to me she wouldn't
[__] do it now
hold meatball here nope putting fingers
Ron DeSantis [__] Neo-Nazi I don't
not I'm not I don't have I'm listen he's
a Neo-Nazi because a Neo-Nazi say so not
me I'm just listening to what the
neo-nazis are saying and they support
the Santas they love DeSantis so I'm
just assuming that he's a [__]
Neo-Nazi and I'm not making the
Assumption I'm telling you he's a
[__] neo-Nazi
he is he is talking about John fetterman
in a way that he would never
never
not in a million [__] years say this
to John fetterman's face
John fetterman
would say a lot of [__] Tyrone DeSantis
face
that she Federman is that's why he wears
a [__] hoodie you [__] bonehead
DeSantis you [__] idiot he's one of
us dumbass
the common folk not [__] some goddamn
elitist
who [__] tortured people at gitmo who
begged Trump to endorse him to become
the governor of Florida
and now and now wants us to believe that
he's not weird and awkward
get the [__] out of here man
John fetterman would chew you up and
spit you out [__]
100 percent pound the ever loving [__]
adironda santis and that is why Rhonda
santis would never
ever
say this [__] to John fetterman's face
not a million years this [__] hoodie
gate [__] he says it behind his little
microphone but listen to what he says I
want you to I want you to think about
like common [__] people wearing
hoodies right common folk wearing
hoodies listen to what how he demeans it
listen
he wears like sweatshirts and hoodies
and shorts and that's his thing so he
would campaign in that which is your
prerogative right I mean if that's what
you want to do but to show up in the
United States Senate with that and not
have the decency to put on proper attire
I think it's disrespectful to the body
and I think the fact that the Senate
changed the rules to accommodate that
um you know I think looks speaks very
poorly uh to how they consider that look
we need this country we need to be
lifting up our standards in this country
not dumbing down our standards in this
country
Ron DeSantis is telling us not to dumb
things down
the guy is Banning books the guy's
Banning books and he's forcing
curriculum to ignore the truth about
history and he's telling us that a
hoodie and shorts for crying out loud
hoodies and shorts are gonna dumb
Americans get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense meatball you piece of
trash wait oh listen
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do Ron when you
become president are you gonna sign an
executive order
ordering the execution of anyone who
wears a hoodie on the floor of the
Senate I mean you don't care and due
process of law you don't give a [__] if
someone crosses a mayor engineering line
with a [__] backpack oh boy shoot him
on sight especially if they're [__]
Brown
so what makes me believe that Rhonda
Santos is the president United States
wouldn't order
anyone who walks on to the United States
Senate for not to be executed on site
because they were wearing sweatshirt in
shorts
what makes me believe that huh what
makes you believe that huh [__] this guy
[__] Rhonda santis and he won his Sports
Ron DeSantis [__] him
and listen nothing says lifting up the
Common Man
Ron DeSantis like [__] on folks who
wear hoodies and shorts in this country
you piece of trash what a [__]
[__] and what a what a bunch of
[__] you think that's a good clip
I'm not kidding you they posted this
[__] like it was a good thing let me
show you I'll show you Florida's voice
and they're called Florida's voice news
these people really are Brazen aren't
they like oh we'll hide our fascism
behind the word news
but literally Florida boy they think
this is a good thing they think this is
a good thing let me show you something
even better
because there's a quote tweet there's a
quote tweet to this son of a [__] that
you're gonna love oh boy you're gonna
fall in love with fetterman after this
no way you're not going to no [__]
way it won't happen won't happen let me
show you the quote tweet
because John fetterman understands that
how he dresses right he knows that he
gets it he wears them dummy but here's
the video of Ron DeSantis okay here it
is here's the video a Rhonda santis
saying the [__] that he's saying about
ow
common folks shouldn't be allowed on a
senate flooring them but hoodies and
shorts
execute them on site I mean he didn't
say that in the video but I bet he's
going to get there soon don't you I mean
he went from well we really need to have
great border security to execute him on
site if you see a brown guy with a
backpack kill him no due process of law
[__] the Constitution
you don't think he's going to get there
with people on the senate floor come on
but here's the best quote tweet that I
seen
and there's a lot of good ones if you go
in the thread if you're willing to uh
dig to the dumpster fire that Twitter
has become but here's
here's John fetterman himself I dress
like he campaigns
oh my God now John listen I don't really
again I don't really [__] treat tweet
and retweet and
politicians especially sitting
politicians and and ones that are
running too
because then you know I don't want it to
smell like I'm endorsing them because I
you know I'm endorsing democracy
and I'm endorsing the candidate that's
pro-democracy if you want to know the
honest truth that's my feeling uh going
forward for the next probably decade as
long as you're pro-democracy we can work
together that's it period if you're
pro-democracy we can work together and
if you got an R next to your name you're
not pro-democracy sorry man sorry sorry
you've proven it time and time time
again and you keep proving it
when you say stupid [__] like this as if
there's somewhere somewhere in a
document in our founding fathers they
said no hoodies
they're terrified of John fetterman's
hoodie that's the actual truth of it
terrified of his hoodie
terrified that Republicans are actually
I don't know for like um Blue Collar
people seems kind of funny uh let me
show you though a video this is one of
the best videos you know my friend
Justin t Brown our friend here at the
show Justin D Brown he makes great
content uh and this is some of the best
Ben Shapiro content
he dropped this during the campaign in
Pennsylvania for the senate race between
John fetterman the one that they're
terrified of him oh my God can you
imagine a hoodie on the senate floor our
our country will crumble if someone
wears a hoodie on the floor of the
Senate our country just crumble into
ashes
[__] out of here
I'd rather have John fetterman's hoodie
then then Ron desantis's high heel boots
any day of the [__] week okay but
here is Ben Shapiro apparently he kind
of endorsed fetterman during this
campaign let's watch I'd like to
introduce you to John fetterman
he Democrats Pennsylvania Senate Kansas
leading his race against Sacramento John
fetterman is the man yeah
Spider-Man after his full-time mayor of
Braddock Pennsylvania from 2006 to 2019.
he's six foot eight at 2. he's authentic
meanwhile Captain he is inauthentic
watch everybody did the grocery shopping
list
is an ultra millionaire from the Jersey
Shore who's actually a giant loser
sometimes people who claim that they
live at lives like you so if we go
memadize is very bad he's really really
bad so vote for John fetterman because
after all afternoon also a giant loser
in New Jersey right now
thank you
[Applause]
Dave Shapiro I love you
[Music]
and there you have it Ben Shapiro
endorsed
John vetterman obviously that's
um something's been faked there
thank you thank you Justin for that
video and thank you for reposting it
since they're freaking out about John
Federman and it's not really their
hoodie the hoodie that they're freaking
out about but John fetterman
it's not really the hoodie it is the
John fetterman wing of the party
the Democratic Party
the up and coming
part of the party that they're terrified
of now they were really excited when
John Federman
had his health issues
he had a stroke
his speech went away for a while
but they didn't expect because they
really thought they could ruin him in
the meantime they really thought they
could bang him up and ruin him and that
we wouldn't trust us as the Democratic
party or the pro-democracy Coalition
wouldn't trust John fetterman
like somehow because we know how Strokes
work and we know that sometimes stroke
victims you know lose their speech for a
while and it takes a while to get their
speech back right just I mean they have
to go through intensive therapy
I mean it's brutal
like so much so that John fetterman sunk
into a depression because he probably
didn't know if how long it was going to
take and how much work it was going to
be to get his speech back but you know
what they're they're really [__]
scared of not it's not the hoodie I mean
they're pretending it's the hoodie
because they can't say the quiet part
out loud on this one
John Federman has his speech back
John fetterman has his wits about him
John fetterman is going to be a really
really really effective senator for
Pennsylvania and not just for
Pennsylvania but average middle class
working Americans
because he is one of those
he is one of those
and when they're standing next to him
when you if you watched Rhonda if you
saw even if Ron DeSantis had a six inch
high-heeled boots on next to fetterman
fetterman would still Tower over that
[__]
just like the American people should be
towering over the Elites in this [__]
country like Rhonda santis and Donald
Trump pretending pretending to be blue
collar get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense Blue Collar my [__] ass
and then you [__] over people who are
wearing hoodies and shorts and you think
you're gonna be [__] support the
common man you think you're gonna be you
think you're gonna [__] gain our
support when you [__] all over us
wearing hoodies especially when you [__]
over John fetterman wearing a hoodie
they're terrified of John fetterman and
they're more terrified about the
Coalition of blue-collar Democrats that
are going to come straight for their ass
straight for their fascist ass that's
what they're terrified of the John
fetterman brand of the party the Tony
Michaels brand of the [__]
pro-democracy Coalition that's what
they're terrified of
hell even some of the Democrats and
Liberals are terrified terrified of that
brand
absolutely mortified when someone when
someone says the Russian ball of the
left about me
oh my God it shakes them it shakes
lefties to their cord like oh that's bad
that's really bad that branded get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense
it's time it's time that we get our [__]
together and put our [__] boxing
gloves on and get in the ring and punch
us some Nazis
and fetterman's willing to do it he
don't give a [__]
he don't care if you don't like that it
took him a while to do the hard work of
getting his speech back so that he had
he had his he had was able to be able to
speak and ask questions and hearings for
his constituents and do the work that he
needs to do for the people of
Pennsylvania he don't give a [__] he
don't care if you don't like because he
wears shorts or hoodies he don't give a
[__] if you if you if you think he's
some kind of big dumb idiot or that he's
changing his facial hair because it's
not the real John fetterman
they're terrified of John fetterman and
more than anything they're terrified of
that brand being in the Democratic party
because they know what that means
they're gonna lose middle class and
working Americans if that brand sticks
and the harder we get that brand to
stick the better off we are
so support John betterman support the
Common working man and support hoodies
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
every
single weekday
right here on YouTube twitch and the
books
you're watching
Facebook
which a lot of folks do they watch this
show all over the place now you notice
that we have we've reduced the places
that we broadcast this and it's it's
having a good effect that is part of the
expansion that we're doing here at the
Tony Michaels podcast also you notice
that Gabe Sanchez is doing a second or
an hour a third hour of the [__] fam
Universe here right after my show on
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays on a
regular basis this week it's Monday and
Tuesday because he's got a special trip
he's making so he's gonna be on right
after this show so you're not going to
want to go anywhere
you're not going to want to go in here
what you're going to want to do is stick
right here on the main YouTube channel
or on Twitch and you'll go directly to
Gabe Sanchez's live what was that
um with Gabe Sanchez let's check in why
we're talking about
YouTube channels oh my God
so you're going to want to subscribe to
Gabe's YouTube channel when you get over
there and I really appreciate you guys
doing that you got him over ten thousand
that's freaking awesome
he got over 10 000 subscribers
we're over 18 000. we're on our way to
19. we should be on our way to 20 soon
so if you're if you're not subscribed to
the Tony Michaels podcast hit that
subscribe button right now
the library of democracy now has 430
430. that is awesome we're halfway to
our today's goal and we're just you know
we're just at halfway
um done with the show
just over halfway so we're almost there
we can get to a thousand I know we can
over on the library democracy so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna post
the link to the library democracy's
YouTube channel in the chat right now so
go over there for me real quick hit
subscribe for the library democracy and
get back over at the show because I'm
going to show you some clips
and I'm going to show you some rake
stepping so go do that really quick go
over there subscribe to the library
democracy and then come back over here
and I'm going to show you some rake
stepping you guys want to see some
[__] just professional rake stepping
oh my god do I have some rake stepping
to show you
and it's it's great it's great rakes
that they're throwing out in front of
themselves and really honestly I mean
the the government shutdown is going to
hurt um our economy and our nation it's
going to hurt us it's going to make us
less prepared it's it's not it's going
to weaken us but that's what Republicans
do like so this should be expected when
you elect Republicans to any kind of
government County School Board state
government federal government and you
give them control of any kind of
um how you govern it's going to affect
you poorly it's gonna suck it's gonna
suck and really honestly this country
needs to realize this so they're going
to make us realize this and the way that
they're going to do that is they're
going to really make it suck to be in
this country for for a while
it's gonna suck and the reason why is
because they're going to shut down the
government and they're going to keep it
shut down until Donald Trump says so Bet
On It bet
again hey why don't we put that
prediction in the doubt me channel on
Discord there's a doubt me channel on
Discord where they
um
they take my predictions and we see if
they come true
um so we're probably gonna have to put
that one in there that um that yeah
they're gonna keep the government shut
down and tell Donald Trump tells them
they need to open it back up
at his orders okay because they're
delusional and they're they're [__]
sheep all of them even even the cowards
that are in Congress this is why this is
why you don't give the reins of power to
a party that doesn't believe in
democracy you do not give them the reins
of power in a democracy when they don't
believe in it especially when they don't
know how to govern they have no [__]
clue how to govern for eight years they
were Mitch McConnell's like
uh I'm gonna make sure Brock
Obama
is a one-term president that's you know
glitchy Mitchy
but glitchy Mitchy remember eight years
they did nothing obstruct obstruct
obstruct obstruct obstruct no governing
whatsoever none seems like they like
obstruction too doesn't it now that
we're thinking about this uh obstructing
of the classified documents maybe he got
that maybe he got that principle
somewhere
but here's the thing
they are always going to step on these
rakes like the government shutdown the
country is gonna blame them no matter
how they spin it no matter what they do
right the country's gonna just like they
were like last week they were like
ceiling fans are gonna ban they're gonna
ban ceiling fans and everyone's like no
they're not and then Ted Cruz like
they're only gonna let us drink two
beers a week and everyone's like no
they're not
provide Escape here it's queer beard no
it's not Kid Rock is drinking it again
okay you know all the [__] you say is
you're full of [__]
Hunter Button he's a criminality he's
yeah oh we don't like his dick but we
like to look at pictures yeah we know
you like to look at this pictures of his
dick we get it we get it but all these
are great steps that they continue to do
to themselves and really honestly not
only should we encourage them to step on
their own ranks we should throw out as
many rakes as we possibly can
for them to jump on right well one of
the drink one of the breaks that they're
stepping on this morning is the one with
Ray Epps
do you know who Ray Epps is a few people
have mentioned it in the comments today
because this is big news and it's really
not that big a news it's really not it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be that big a
news that Ray Epps is being charged with
a felony this morning for January 6. he
is he's being charged with a felony for
January 6. he's a fed he's a Fed yeah
see here's the thing [__] normally
the feds don't charge felony charges to
another fed it's a thing they don't do
see that that's why you cooperate with
the beds is to not comp a charge so if
he was a plant and he was a fed and
they're going to be like I swear to God
they're going to be like Tony see you're
just you're not thinking with your
Noggin see the thing is is that they're
charging him to make sure that you don't
know that he's a fan yeah you're dumb as
dog [__] okay you're stupid as [__] it's
not a thing and the only reason why we
know who rayaps is
cause they freaked out about him oh man
The ray-ups Conspiracy Theory his son
was starting to something now he's
charged with something he's not a fed
now here's here's Kyle Chaney reporting
this uh just in reyups charged with a
single count for January 6 conduct
um now let me let me show you the the
conduct in this let's see hey well he
doesn't have a picture of it here now
here he goes appears to be a plea deal
this is a single Petty offense
not for the typical four misdemeanors
we've seen uh what details emerge
rayup's Target for conspiracy theories
Amplified by Trump is pleading guilty to
a single misdemeanor disorderly conduct
charge for his involvement in the
January sixth month excuse me I said
felony I meant to say misdemeanor it is
a misdemeanor and they're going to say
yeah but yeah he's a fan that's why
they're charging him
again they're going to make up stupid
[__] and they're going to step on this
rake but let them let them step on this
rake let them step on this rake let them
continue to do this stupid [__]
now again Ray Epps being charged and
doing a plea deal with the misdemeanor
for disorderly conduct should not be
news
it wouldn't be like honestly you
wouldn't even know who the [__] Ray Epps
was and you wouldn't even know that he
was charged this morning no one would
even tweet that [__]
no one no one would report on Ray Epps
pleading to a misdemeanor disorderly
conduct charge at the Capitol on January
6th the only reason why is because the
right are [__] idiots
and they look for stupid rakes to step
on all the time all the time and this is
one of them
this is one of them
oh boy you want to see another rank I
got you another rake let's see
oh I had it right here uh here is uh
Daniel Goldman throwing
this is this isn't like the normal rake
step like they stepped on the rake and
then Daniel Goldman just holds it in
their face you know what I mean you know
what I mean by that like they step on
the rank and they stand on it maybe
Goldman is just
keeps [__] beating the [__] out of
him you know what I mean
this is Daniel Goldman destroying
Republican Nazi Hypocrites in less than
30 seconds on the floor of the house
listen to this this is [__] beautiful
recognized one of my colleagues says we
will hold members accountable you are
the party of George Santos
who are you holding accountable
the guy is an alleged and acknowledged
liar and indicted and you protect him
every day Don't lecture us with your
projection and your defense of Donald
Trump it's pathetic and it's beneath you
and it's beneath this body and I yield
back
again this is an old clip
but use it use this clip this is a
perfect clip to use
over and over and over and over and over
and over again have you seen one
Republican
out there
speaking against Lauren bobert what she
did when she was juicing the beetle have
you seen one have you heard one
just one get them from a microphone say
some something something nope
fetterman's hoodie fetterman's hoodie
veterans hoodie footie veterans hoodie
fetterman City veterans hoodie oh it's
the demon uh it's the devil it's gonna
come and get you that [__] hoodie
yesterday that's all they talked about
was federman's [__] hoodie
not talking about [__] Lauren bobert
juicing the beetle of a goddamn Democrat
bar owner who has drag shows at his bar
now I don't know if they had sex or not
after they left the theater my guess is
yes
that's my guess
I mean I'm not I'm not
I'm not accusing him or her of anything
I'm just saying it looked like they were
gonna do something silly
after they got done you know juicing the
beetle right I'm just saying just saying
I'm sure
there was some
uglies bumping right is that zero days I
think that's zero days we need to Mark
zero days
she had sex with him 100 a demon did you
hear what I said a demon
a demon she had sex with this is a
Democrat who owns a bar
who allows not only gay people's bar but
host drag shows at this very bar he's a
demon
doesn't that make her
seated by a demon I don't know I don't
know I don't know what they did after
the show we don't have footage of that
maybe thank God or some people might not
be like I really want that footage
depends on how you feel about Lauren
bobert I guess
but aren't we I mean and again I I know
it sounds crazy and but listen they're
[__] hypocrites
they're [__] Hypocrites and that's
what Goldman is saying in this clip when
they were trying to censure Adam Schiff
when they won't do [__] about George
Santos or Marjorie Taylor green or Matt
gatz or
Lauren Beetle the juice or juice the
beetle
other [__] clowns
okay well you want to see more clownery
I know you do I know you do want to see
more clownery especially on the house
floor with these [__] idiots here is
a clip
of Matt gatz performing theater this was
yesterday I believe this was during or
just after the show
uh he's performing theater
here it's all theater with this CR and
the reason why is because they know
they're going to be blamed for shutting
down the government so they have to do
this [__] where they're pretending that
they're gonna try to keep it open and so
Kevin McCarthy's doing he's pretending
and it's all theater
to act like to tell the American see
we're we're trying this really hard
we're doing what we can do to uh see we
we want to keep the government up but
yeah but we're not going to fund the uh
Biden and um government and and in
general because they don't know how to
govern
it's a [__] distraction now a lot of
people see this as some sort of Civil
War here with Matt Gatson Byron Donalds
but again they're running rough shot
over our institutions and they're
distracting you and I'm gonna show it to
you here listen or three I oppose the CR
authored by my friend and colleague from
Florida Byron Donalds the Donald CR
continues the Ukraine policy negotiated
by Speaker Pelosi and Mitch McConnell in
the Omnibus that conservatives were
against
the Donald CR is a permission slip for
Jack Smith to continue his election
interference as they are trying to gag
the president the former president
United States and the leading Contender
for the Republican nomination and the
Donald CR abandons the principle that it
is only a review of single subject
spending bills that will save this
country and allow us to tweeze through
these programs and force these agencies
to stand up and defend their budget my
friends we are approaching the days
where we're facing two trillion dollar
annual deficits atop a 33 trillion
dollar debt this is unsustainable and
just to continue things with some facial
eight percent cut over 30 days that will
lead to no programmatic reform
is an insult to the principles we fought
for in January okay rapey mcforhead here
all of a sudden oh man he cares about
the budget
[__] out of here with this theater okay
I'm gonna rewind a bit
remember how they were gonna have an
impeachment uh we're gonna peach tree
and Peach impeachment uh Joe Biden we're
gonna impeach him because Hunter Biden
likes to take pictures of his dick I
don't know what they're gonna impeach
him for who the [__] knows because
they're not gonna impeach him remember
that was the whole talk last week I had
to do a show on it and during the show
Kevin McCarthy came out right before the
show and said we're gonna we're gonna
pretend to impeach Joe Biden that's what
he said and the reason why he said it is
because this idiot this [__] idiot
rapy mcforhead Matt Getz
was gonna go to the floor
to ask to remove Kevin McCarthy if he
didn't do what he wanted and the reason
why is because it's the lead up of the
government shutting down
there's one thing Kevin McCarthy knows
is that
he is going to have to shut the
government down
the reason why is because [__] like
this who don't give a [__] about our
country Mac ants does not give two shits
about the [__] he's talking about in
this clip he doesn't even care if Byron
Donalds did a CR
actually if you want to know the [__]
truth Byron Donald's and Matt Getz
probably cooked this up
this is all theater
all of it I don't give a [__] what the
pundits tell you I don't give a [__]
what the reporters on Capitol Hill tell
you this is theater
it is all theater
they pretend
everything everything's pretend it's not
real it's all fraudulent
they're frauds the whole lot of them
Matt Getz doesn't give a [__] about the
budget he doesn't give a [__] about it
when's the last time you heard Matt Getz
get all wonky on the budget [__] out of
here man
you can't even you can't even keep your
[__] drugs and sex trafficking venmos
private and you want you expect me to
believe that somehow you're gonna be
really serious and wonky about the
budget all of a sudden
son come on man sit the [__] down
[__] the [__] down
enough of the forehead [__] okay
but this is all this is all shitty
theater
Byron Donald's everyone's gonna cook up
CRS and they're gonna throw
intentionally stuff in there so mecats
can go to the floor and oppose the CR in
public so that way they have a
justification to shut the government
down
and they can say we tried we really did
try we really did try hard to keep the
government open so we can meet Joe Biden
for Hunter Biden's hog
I don't know
I don't know I just I know this
that this is all fake it's all [__]
because everything they do is faking
[__] even Lauren bobert her stupid
little [__] remember when she
remember when she was like
to the DC Council you know the
Washington DC the city council she's
like so did you make peeing in public
legal
exposing yourself and remember when she
was really focused
on pissing in public whether it was
going to be a [__] misdemeanor or
whatever you remember this
you remember this
you'll remember right
she was all [__] upset in a hearing
and of course she stepped on that rake
because they're like no we did not make
we didn't decriminalize whipping your
dick out and pissing in public that's
not a thing we didn't do that I mean
some people wanted us to but we didn't
do that so she stepped on that rake and
then this bonehead is in the theater
playing with some guy's wiener through
his pants
playing pocket pull with the guy
while he's grabbing her her as someone
said honking her Hooters during the show
okay really we're worried about people
pissing in public that's your main
concern come on man just like Matt
gantz's main concern is some wonky
[__] he's worried about the budget
Matt get come on
come on man you can't convince me that
rapey mcforhead here excuse me Mick five
head someone's saying five head in the
chat rapey mcfive head here
is worried about the budget
don't believe a single [__] thing
that you see from these idiots
it's not real
just like when they're citing polls or
they're going on the news or whatever
the [__] they're doing this [__] is fake
it's all [__] it's [__] fraud
and you know why they're doing it
they're not doing it for [__] people
like us that can rub bring sales
together and realize this stuff
they're doing it for their sheep just
like I told you the other day the reason
why Donald Trump [__] goes and does
those interviews and lies and talks
about the presidential records act and
say some dumb ass [__] just the dumbest
[__] ever in an interview about his
crimes is because he's talking to his
sheep
he's talking
to his sheep
and again like a lot of people are
saying in the chat here but Sherry has
it on Facebook she says it's a
distraction
yes it's a distraction because what
they're going to try to do is distract
you from them not being able to keep the
government open because that's the real
thing here they can't keep the
government open that's how in that's how
[__] inept they are that's how bad
they can't govern they can't even do the
simple thing of keeping government open
let alone let alone [__] be any kind
of Representative for their constituents
they can't let their constituents know
that [__] so they have to distract their
constituents again they're not doing it
for us the people who know what the [__]
they're doing we got enough brain cells
still rubbed together and realize Q
anon's all [__] right
I mean it doesn't take many brain cells
to realize Q anon's all [__] but you
know we gotta have them
but they're distracting their sheep is
what they're doing I mean I I know you
don't think it's true but they're going
to blame the government shutdown
on coveted lockdowns Biden coveted
lockdowns
get I'm gonna play a clip in the next I
mean it's September 19th
so come October probably that first week
second week in October I'm gonna be
playing you a clip
of some dumb ass Republican some
Republican Nazi on some Trader TV News
Network somewhere
talking about the reason why
everything's locked down is because of
Biden covet policies
mark it down write it down go put it in
the Discord in the doubt me thing I
think it's that one's already in there I
believe that one's already in there I'm
gonna blame it on Kobe lockdowns trust
me it's gonna happen
they're gonna blame it on it speaking of
blaming people
oh boy this Molly Michaels
this Molly Michael story have you heard
this story yep we're gonna go through it
here Molly Michaels
um it was Trump's assistant
she's the one that had to go [__]
tell Jack Smith
that he was writing notes that they were
using classified documents as [__]
scrap sheets of paper
I'm not kidding you
so apparently well let me just let me
play this clip maybe this will help the
story because I didn't know who the [__]
Molly Michaels was until this morning
but she is apparently Trump employee
number two Donald Trump's closest aides
has told Federal investigators that the
former president wrote her notes
specifically to-do lists on the back of
documents marked classified using the
documents as if they were pieces of
scrap paper according to sources
familiar with the aid statements the aid
Molly Michael served as Trump's personal
secretary in the White House her desk
right outside the Oval Office she stayed
with Trump when he left office working
closely with him as his personal
secretary in both Mar-A-Lago and
Bedminster New Jersey until last fall
she has told investigators that the note
she received from Trump were written on
the back of note cards with visible
classification markings that had been
used to brief the former president for
meetings and calls with foreign leaders
in other National related matters Molly
Michael according to the sources went to
Mar-A-Lago the day after the FBI
searched the property listened to this
card this is important that she
discovered some of those notes that
Trump had written to her on the back of
classified documents were still there
underneath a divider in one of her desk
drawers she then made arrangements to
turn them over to the justice department
as ABC News has previously reported
Molly Michael is identified as Trump
employee number two and special counsel
Jack Smith's indictment in the
classified documents case and she was
involved in handling many of the boxes
later seized by the FBI in fact
according to sources familiar with the
investigation it was Michael who took
the photos of the boxes for Trump that
later showed up in Smith's indictment
still Michael told investigators
according to sources that when she told
Trump the FBI wanted to speak with her
the former president replied you know
nothing about the boxes
oh you know nothing about
the boxes
that
a little bit like what's the word
obstruction that's what it is that's
what it is that's what that's
obstruction of justice that's what that
is okay I get it I get it see when I was
telling you yesterday and today that
don't [__] pay an attention when they
get all riled up about what Donald Trump
said in an interview
okay do not get all riled up about the
media's like oh he confessed to a crime
he confessed you a crime in this
interview
and they're gonna play that interview
bam they're gonna have him
[__] out of here
Jack Smith
has a world and mountains more of
evidence against Donald Trump than he'll
ever dream of
and he has his most personal AIDS she
was his [__] personal secretary here
[__] desk was sitting right next to
his okay he was writing her notes on the
back of classified documents
and this little [__] is going and
talking to Jack Smith
and telling Jack Smith that when she was
she was when she was supposed to go talk
to Jack Smith but this [__] the
dude said you don't know nothing about
them boxes
listen to me when I tell you this
pay attention very closely
when I say this
because it you're going to want to put
this into predictions too my guess is is
that in open court When Donald Trump
finally goes to criminal trial for this
document's case which is likely going to
be after the election because if you
don't know
the [__] about Canon judge Cannon
recusing himself was all [__] just
like I said it was and she's going to
remain the judge and she's going to punt
this thing and punt this thing past the
election for the documents case okay
that's what's gonna happen
just know that trust me don't doubt me I
mean you can if you want to doubt me but
you'll be wrong
he's not going to go to trial for this
document's case till after the election
he does go to trial
Jack Smith is not going to have to
hardly talk about any interviews he's
given
because all the [__] that Donald Trump
has confessed to in the interviews Jack
Smith has material evidence of that he
will present to a jury in open trial and
it'll be much more effective when Jack
Smith gives the jury material evidence
and says this is why this is his
motivations this is what it is and this
is why he said this on this interview
that is how it's gonna work it's not
gonna be he said this on this interview
so he's guilty no that's not how it's
gonna work Jack Smith and the
prosecutors are going to present the
material evidence and back up why he
said what he said on the interview
because he did the thing that he said he
did here's the material evidence that's
how it's gonna [__] work folks
that's how it's gonna work that's why
he's so [__] why do you think Molly
Michael doesn't work for him anymore
it's been damn near a year
since she worked for him and the reason
why the reason why is because when she
came back to Mar-A-Lago after the FBI
search she was looking at her desk and
going well [__] me they missed some
scrap pieces of paper
and she had to go turn I mean they're
not actually scrap beats the paper
they're actually classified documents
that these [__] chuckleheads were
using in scrap pieces of paper
okay
that's how much they give a [__] about
our national security these [__]
idiots
that's how much he gives a [__]
about our government about our [__]
intelligence agencies and the people
risking their lines to collect that
intelligence that goes into those
classified documents so much he gives a
[__] about it that's how much he gives a
[__] about you and your family that he's
willing to just willy-nilly [__] just
take classified documents and use them
as scrap piece of paper no matter who
the [__] gets in that Destroyer he don't
give a [__] he don't care about you he
don't care about this nation's security
the [__] out of here
and if you if you still if you still
believe that you are a dumb [__]
and you you are deluded you are a sheep
you need to seek [__] help and that's
one thing we need to get health care and
then we need to get Mental Health and
Care in this country fast for these
people who still believe this guy isn't
a [__] treasonous piece of garbage
but think about this she returned to
Mar-A-Lago after the FBI search opened
up her [__] desk drawer and they're
in the desk drawer is classified
documents that he's made notes on like
they're [__] Post-it notes
and she has to go turn them in because
she knows that she's oh my God she's
probably been told by an attorney by
this point but if you [__] see
classified documents anywhere you say
something
because you're gonna get criminally
charged like like [__] Walt team
cracker nada
oh excuse me Walt teen NADA your Saltine
molting I I get it confused
oh that's one thing it'll give me banned
on YouTube
they don't like when you say the word
cracker they hate it anyways I digress
from that
but the minute she has these documents
that and she has to go turn them over to
doj
dude looks at her and is like when you
go talk to him you don't know [__] about
these boxes
because she knew everything about the
boxes
she was [__] taking pictures of the
she was lying and obstructing about the
boxes knowingly or unknowingly
by Donald Trump
and I bet there's more material evidence
that Donald Trump
said you don't know nothing about these
boxes let me ask you something
would you would just put yourself in a
scenario here and I know it's hard to
imagine all right I get it I know it's
hard to imagine
well let's just say let's just say you
decided one day that you were gonna go
work and be Donald Trump's personal
secretary just bear with me bear with me
okay and you know this guy is a criminal
[__] scumbag and the only thing he
can do is commit felonies felony here
felony there felony everywhere right day
after day after day
Guy Can't Stop committing felonies
and all over the country to be quite
honest New York Georgia D.C Florida
Arizona Michigan
Pennsylvania it's like I've Been
Everywhere man you heard that song I've
Been Everywhere man I've Been Everywhere
I've been to Reno Chicago Fargo
Minnesota Buffalo geronto Winslow
Sarasota Wichita Tulsa Ottawa Oklahoma
Tampa Panama matawa Paloma Bank of
Baltimore Salvador Amarillo Toca
Billerica I'm a killer I committed
felonies I committed felonies
this guy's commit felonies all over the
country
and you believe
that this personal secretary
who's who has right there in their
pocket more than likely
a recording device on their [__]
smartphone and you think
you think
that she hasn't recorded conversations
would you not record every [__]
conversation you had with this goddamn
Criminal
wouldn't you
record every [__] conversation you
have with this chucklehead at that point
right the FBI has been rated Mar-A-Lago
with a Criminal [__] warrant
right
come in search for [__]
the FBI is telling you hey if you find
anything else you can hand it over the
doj immediately
this guy's obstructing like crazy and
you know he is because your desk is
right next to his
her desk is right there she's right
there with him she knows he's a [__]
Criminal
and you don't think
you don't think that she's recording him
come on
wouldn't you record him I there's no
[__] way I would be in a room with
Donald Trump alone or with a small group
of people and me not be recording from
my [__] pocket no [__] I don't
even care if it's against the law no
[__] way would I put my myself in a
position where I'm in a room with that
[__] and I'm not recording the
conversation and the criminal [__] he's
saying to me
at least at the end of the day if I get
charged by because I'm recording without
consent at least I'm not going to
[__] prison for dozens of felonies
that this guy has drugged me into like
waltin nada
Noah Wade and Molly Michael want to end
up that way that's why she stopped
working for Donald Trump
why do you think yes
100 [__] percent she recorded him
she's got recordings she's got material
evidence
of Donald Trump committing [__]
obstruction
Garen goddamn tea it
and Jack Smith has his [__] hands all
over that evidence
why do you think they charge him with
[__] obstruction
think about the timing
think about it last fall she quit
working for him she handed over these
documents
Trump employee number two went and
talked to the special counsel and the
grand jury
and he gets charged with obstruction
hmm
use your brain a lot of people are
wondering about the song that I was
singing uh Hank Snow
some people are saying Hank Snow Hank
Snow did sing that
did sing that song I've Been Everywhere
Man
I've been towed in my pack along the
dusty Winnemucca road but John John
Johnny Cash re-recorded that's probably
a more popular version it is Johnny Cash
I think some people were saying
it was Johnny Cash but yes
um Johnny Cash recorded that that that's
probably the most recent recording that
is popular
and um he um
Rick Rubin is the one he that he uh he
recorded that with I believe I forget
which album
it is on it it it it sneaks away from me
for a second
um when he's saying Woody Guthrie he's
saying it too which is probably probably
true I think Woody probably would have
sang that
um but my my favorite version
is Johnny's version
I mean Johnny is of course a legend in
country music
but
who the version that he is voice you
know what I mean at that stage in his
life his voice was so great
um Johnny's Johnny's was
but no I I can sing I I've Been
Everywhere man I've Been Everywhere
across the deserts bare man I breathe
the mountain there it's a great song
it's a great song and it's a great party
trick
when you um
when you sing it yeah everyone's saying
Woody Guthrie if you guys know what he
got there is
what do you got there he's the one with
the guitar it says this machine kills
fascism or fascist I should say this
machine kills fascist that's where that
comes from go look up Woody Guthrie
definitely want to look him up speaking
of country music artists I didn't plan
on covering this but you know since
we're talking about this real quick
um
her name is Marin Morris she's a popular
country music star
she basically told Nashville and Country
Music this week to go [__] themselves
she says she's done with country music
she's not gonna do that [__] anymore a
lot of people are mad at her
but the reason why she's she's doing it
I mean there is a reason why is because
some of the Bro country [__] like me and
Tennessee Brando talked about several
several weeks ago when the Jason Aldean
[__] hit
and then we talked about the Oliver
Anthony stuff you remember this
um it's kind of crazy
that uh that they would chastise her for
saying I don't I don't want to be in
that scene I like country music I want
to record country music but I'm not
going to be a part of that culture
at [__] bro country [__] racist
bigoted [__] because that's not what
country music is about and me me and me
and uh Tennessee Randall talked about
country music and history country music
and you go look at like Johnny Cash or
or Woody Guthrie but let's let's take
Johnny Cash For example Johnny Cash
worked hard
to get dudes out of prison
he went and he performed at prisons
I mean he has a song called Man in Black
and the whole premise of the song
is that he wears black for the
downtrodden
in solidarity
with folks
who work hard in this country who can't
make it who could barely make it people
who have problems
people have challenges in their life
right maybe the same kind of solidarity
that John fetterman when he wears his
sweat his hoodie his sweater and his
shorts
maybe the same solidarity
as common folk in this country
and Johnny Cash had that and he was he
was country music
and Johnny Cash wasn't just country
music
he walked across the line his and he has
a song
walk the line but he walked across the
line when his his songs would be on pop
charts and Country charts
and we forget these things in history we
forget the Woody Guthries the folk
Heroes like Woody Guthrie and John Prine
the great folk artist who sang songs
that were against the establishment
that were against the politicians that
were against the the seed of power
and their music spoke truth to power not
[__] capitulated to power
I mean there's been racist in country
music history
but it doesn't mean that country music
history is racist or definitely racist
country music artists and have been
since the very beginning
but it's not rooted and I applaud her
for telling them to [__] off
because here's the thing is that country
music isn't racist
they've developed a fan base that is
[__] racist
and what they do is they they capitulate
to that fan base
to their followers to Their audience
right I'm here to tell you it is a
difficult thing to build an audience
it's [__] difficult this [__]
it's one of the most difficult things
I've ever done
I've done some difficult [__] in my life
but this is one of the most difficult
things that I've ever done
is to
is to build an audience and they tried
to do it the easy way which was just
appeal to people's worst [__] traits
their hatred their bigotry their [__]
racism and just you know write songs
about that and then they'll be attracted
to us right well the problem is is now
that's their audience
now they have to keep writing that
garbage they have to keep feeding that
trash because their audience wants that
trash right I keep telling you about the
media and why the media is trash is
because they're trying to feed stuff to
people that they want to hear
that's why the right wing media is trash
and the mainstream media is trash
because they're just trying to feed you
what you want to eat
and it's the same thing and I applaud
her for telling Nashville and Country
Music the [__] off
um I've got I've got a uh announcement
to make the mighty Librarian Is back
from Constitution Day so it sounds like
she's listening
um so I want to show this here and this
is really cool we had a goal today of
getting
um the library of democracy's YouTube
channel
we had a goal today to get it to a
thousand and I I'm here to announce that
we haven't quite made it to a thousand
yet but I want to show this to you
um this is this is the library of
democracy's Channel as it speaks I think
I think we had 95 or 92 something like
that when we started the show today I
want to show this to you this is the
library of democracy's YouTube channel
we're at 495 subscribers
how happy [__] Constitution Day
for the library of democracy that is
[__] incredible now if you if you are
not subscribed to the library of
democracy's YouTube channel you're gonna
want to and you're going to want to do
it right now I'm going to put the link
in the chat right so no matter if you're
on Facebook or twitch or YouTube here
this is going to be the link to the
YouTube channel I want you to go right
now I want you to get us over 500 we're
going to try to get to a thousand today
we're really going to try hard to get to
a thousand for happy Constitution Day so
this is our celebration here at the Tony
Michaels podcast
for the Constitution Day just go and
subscribe to the library of democracies
oh my God 515 we just passed it
you guys are [__] awesome
[__] awesome
again if you're if you're listening
right now and you can hear this go to
the link in the chat the library
democracy or if you're if this isn't the
live if you're not watching this live
you're watching this recorded or
listening it's recorded go to YouTube
just type in the library of democracy
it's at library of democracy at library
of democracy on YouTube and hit
subscribe it doesn't cost you a single
dime and You're Gonna Wanna Have This at
your fingertips because these videos are
not just going to be good for you to
learn how to engage in no quick tips on
how to engage but where to find those
resources what resources are out there
it's going to be so important because
it's not just going to be content on how
to engage it's going to be a library of
all that content because we don't have
to reinvent the wheel here
of Engagement we have all these great
resources out there to engage in our
democracy with
we just gotta glue them together right
we just gotta glue them together
so I want to thank everyone who has
already subscribed and if you're not go
subscribe now to the library of
democracy tell your friends about it
share it share the videos share the post
on on Twitter on Facebook on threads you
can also go to linktree and and do that
there and the link tree is on the
YouTube page just click the link tree
you can go follow them on all social
media but please do me this favor
let's make it a hell of a Constitution
Day
hell of a Constitution Day and let's do
it by celebrating and doing something
that we all can do to to contribute to
our great country and our great
Constitution and subscribe to the
library of democracy you're not going to
want to miss this content that's going
to come out of this
um it is going to be it's going to be
great
um so 587 subscribers you guys are
[__] great
I think we can still get to a thousand
we got like 10 minutes left and Gabe
Sanchez is going to be joining us soon I
believe I believe so maybe maybe not I I
thought he was going to come in
um before which he's probably gonna come
in like five minutes before
you coming in before
your show
said send him that message
you guys are awesome we got 10 minutes
left uh to get to get the library
democracy and we got all day it's
Constitution Day today so I'm gonna
report back tomorrow
rather we got over a thousand or not
okay
we're gonna get over and
we're gonna get over a thousand today
is what we're gonna do 602 now is that
what it's at
let's see Let me refresh here and I'll
show it to you guys
let me show you your work in action 605
now
we're over 600 600 here yeah
yep yep
I'm now marching auctioning off that's a
different song
it's called the auctioneer it's Leroy
Van Dyke
see I know my music I know my country
music God damn it
[Laughter]
oh
um
and also again you can go follow once
you follow them on YouTube the library
of democracy
and you get there we're gonna have
shorts there's there's already a couple
videos over there on bellapedia there's
going to be shorts giving you quick
actionable directions just little things
that you can do or little things you
should know how to do
if you need those little things to
you know to engage in your democracy and
because that's what the library
democracy is all about it's all about
getting all those resources out there
that the pro-democracy Coalition already
has and gluing them together for you and
making it to where you can find them
easily and you can use them easily
that's the whole point that's the point
of a library isn't it and it's so great
that we have an actual librarian
uh who is at the helm of this library of
democracy this this digital landscape of
library that we're going to glue
pro-democracy Coalition resources
together with and it's no no better to
have an actual librarian at our
fingertips in the [__] fam community
and the uni [__] fam Universe the
mighty librarian
um again give her a round of applause on
on Constitution Day for this
pro-democracy effort to share and to
make sure that people know how to engage
in their democracy and do that for me do
that for me by going to the library of
democracy YouTube channel And subscribe
there it's free again I know I'm
pounding it right now but
it's kind of like a it's kind of like a
a subscriber drive here
as we go 639 we're at 639 I believe
we'll reach a thousand and we'll report
tomorrow on the show and I know we'll
have a thousand by the time we get to
the show because I know you're going to
share this
um with all your friends on social media
you're going to share it with
like-minded people that you know in your
community you're going to tell them go
subscribe to the library democracy
you're going to want to make sure to be
subbed to this channel because they're
going to have so many resources as this
thing goes along it's a lot of work it's
going to take a lot of effort and some
time to get there but we got time and we
can do this together
we can do this together that is one
thing that democracies do is we do
democracy together and we will be at the
battleground of the ballot and from now
until the time that we need to stop
which could possibly be never
but our focus is the ballot in 2024 and
the battle of the ballot in 2024 so
thank you for everyone who has
subscribed to the library of democracy
let's see one more time we've got
650 we're at 650 Gabe Sanchez on the
library of democracy how [__] cool is
that hey do we have the best audience in
the goddamn world or what they're great
they are fantastic aren't they did you
guys speaking of great audience they all
showed up yesterday for your show too
even though it was on Monday and you
know
I kind of have an idea in my head and I
think you probably know what I'm
thinking Monday worked so well that hey
man
no I'm just here's the thing is gaves
week is a little weird because he's got
a vacation and I know it's a little
weird because Texas Paul isn't here
because he's kind of on vacation for the
next couple weeks so next couple weeks
will be a little different but when we
get back on the schedule you're going to
be Tuesday Wednesday Thursday for one
full hour after the show what was that
live with Gabe Sanchez the guy with the
last name Sanchez so tell us what are
you talking about today on what was that
line who knows we'll probably talk about
a little Kevin McCarthy government
shutdown him being a little bit of a
cook
uh who are we talking about uh Tim Scott
you know he's really what what's going
on with Tim Scott Tim Scott what closet
did he walk out of it well he he stepped
out of the closet and said if you strike
you're fired what and then walked right
back into the closet no kidding yeah if
you strike you're fired why did he say
what does that mean well he was quoting
Ronald Reagan which is weird considering
that Ronald Reagan was pro-union when he
was uh yeah well he was a member he was
a member of several he was yeah yeah he
was president of sag yeah that's crazy
so he's the president United States but
he was also president of the I don't
know what do you call those unions is
that what you call them Union yeah
that's weird uh you know the other thing
about unions that you should cover you
should look this up too
um the UAW statement the president's the
the their leadership statement on Donald
Trump and and just look that up maybe
you should talk okay yeah yeah yeah oh
it'll be it'll be a good one so when you
get on the union topic don't forget the
UAW in their statement and then of
course I will probably cover Elon Musk
when you say cover Elon Musk do you mean
like the way that they want to cover up
Russell Brand's crimes or do you mean
like cover like expose these [__]
idiots for who they are I mean you know
exposed oh okay okay yeah yeah I didn't
know if you're able to cover like cover
up Russell Brand yeah yeah and then
there's been obviously an update to the
Lauren bobert situation yeah
is it a good update or is it like it's
an update that she was like well I'm I
won't be going on a second date oh okay
well you know that it was a first date I
I don't know for sure but I would say
you know and maybe I'm
speaking at a turn here but I would say
that the guy next to her because someone
asked someone asked on Twitter I'll
start here someone asked on Twitter what
would you do if Lauren bobert invited
you to to a musical I said I'd sit right
next to her I I mean that's what I I
mean honestly if there was a seat in the
house that I would pick it'd be right
next to Lauren bobert I mean a
Beetlejuice because you know you want
add beetlejuices use the beetle you know
what I mean you want to juice the Beetle
and you want a Hands-On approach I was
going I've been going back and forth
with Jeremy London just if there was a
post I did this morning yeah I gotta
jump but if you want to show people you
can show the background that I've had
with Jeremy one more thing before you go
when you cover Lauren bobert I know I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm going into your own
content but show the UAW thing and then
see what Howard Stern had to say about
Lauren Boger yes okay it's beautiful do
that one do that one dude that's a great
clip that's a great clip I didn't get to
today so you should everybody stick
around on the YouTube channel and the
twitch Channel Gabe Sanchez what was
that line right after this gate go go do
your [__] all right all right see you
later the hell get the hell out of here
uh Gabe Sanchez everybody
um I want to show you
uh something on Elon Musk as we as we
get out of here
um because I don't know if you know this
but Russell Brand has been accused
of rape criminal rape all kinds of [__]
um but one of them is a victim that is
pretty credible even Megan Kelly is
saying hey you should probably believe
this victim and you should probably
question now she's such a [__] both
Siders and a [__]
that she's doing the same thing but this
I found this this morning I think this
was on Facebook live your life in such a
way that people like Tucker Carlson Elon
Musk or Andrew Tate will never come to
your defense which is a good it's a
pretty good it's a pretty good um thing
to live by you really don't want those
[__] defending you
um in any kind of space that there is
now one last clip of uh well
um I wish I had time for this clip you
know what we'll play it tomorrow we're
gonna play it tomorrow if I get to it
we'll play it tomorrow I didn't get to
the Trump
um U.N comparison to Biden Biden's
obviously much smarter than Trump and he
knows more about the world and World
policy and foreign policy than Trump
um so the comparisons for their
statements at the U.N where Joe Biden is
defending democracy and
Donald Trump got laughed because he
doesn't know anything about democracy
um those two clips are in the in the
queue but stick around right here on
YouTube don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere because Gabe Sanchez is going
to talk to you about Elon Musk he's and
he's also going to talk to you about the
updates in Lauren bobert and and about
unions so stick around don't don't go
anywhere because game changers is right
after this and tomorrow we'll be here on
YouTube on Twitch on Facebook same time
same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon